I think I'm gonna be sick
no I just stepped in a dead man's blood
and I think one of the Flies landed on
my mouth if you're going into the
apartments do not go into the lower one
on the right that's where the body is
now if you'll excuse me I need to go
contemplate a hot shower
[Music]
oh sorry sorry
just booked me was all body bag
dispenser empty please replace sack real
before disposing of any courses
[Music]
ooh you're the new face wow you must be
up on all the latest hostile games so
who do you follow wait don't tell me
aren't they just when I get to worrying
about the Marauders outside the Raptor
dance chewing yeah most of the time it's
static on account of the frequency being
called up but sometimes it's tossball
so what can I do for you poor Isaac oh
I'd really like to help Isaac was a
sweet fella
they were pretty distinct monarch
doesn't exactly have a thriving dental
industry and Isaac seemed to get stuck
in all sorts of bad habits dietary and
otherwise sometimes he'd drink purple
berry punched by the leader other times
he'd keep betting on a losing team
started owing the wrong people money I
don't know for sure but I saw Elijah and
his buddies pushing Isaac around they're
hooligans from Fallbrook they sweep into
town drop supplies off behind the
warehouse and spend the rest of the day
getting rowdy Dover tops ball games they
usually loiter in the alley behind the
Yacht Club
they're not allowed in the bar mr.
Sanjar will be pleased to hear about it
when you're done I know he gets fed up
with the Fallbrook bullies but there's
it sounds like rock
what are the chances of all the times in
places you could have been born yeah
we're here light-years from Earth going
about our lives every time the punch
clock
music volume no this ain't you're out
hey what are you doing here this is our
secret ally Berta already pissed by
those crates to market listen
that purple tooth tour had it coming not
that anyone has proof and not that it's
any of your business
oh yeah what are you saying exactly
Wow
most of the pencil pushers around here
cave as soon as you look at him funny
fine we're going this ain't worth it
[Music]
yet another advance well new business
turns up at last Celia
didn't I tell you our new statistics
based advertising model would be a hit
that you did sir
how can yield improvements of 26.7% not
quicken the pulse
how can 32 percent cost savings not
voice in the loins you've often posed
these very questions clear my schedule
this snuke Celia will you make a note of
that for myself through be noted but not
so generous I can't drive it
what a charming note forgive me I'd be
positive
now that's known seems like you're
having a rough time mister oh don't
worry on my account this but I had hoped
that luck Oh fine anyway but that's
terrible what happened I'm glad to hear
you've dealt with them they've been
causing quite a bit of trouble around
town
I've been consumed with other matters of
late but I would have dealt with them
eventually it really what still your
intervention in the matter is much
appreciated